it's that type of day today you bad
[__] Joey where you been
you
what are you nuts or what uncle Joey
here the Lord's Day maybe the Father Son
Holy Spirit
get your [__] together [__]
it's a whole new week
Memorial Day weekend we're on [__]
fire Joey where the [__] you been I've
been under the weather lately my friends
took me at this [__] disgusting place
and between that and the stomach flu I
don't know what the [__] was going on I
had to go to a doctor yesterday and get
this [__] thing to drink but guess
what [__] uncle Joey's back I'm
rested
I slept more this week then I slept the
last [__] 10 years you understand me
I got a good eight and then another
three in the daytime between the fungi
no medication and his [__] flu I was
down but guess what [__] I'm
back [__] we have to church tonight
Tuesday uh Sunday night the Lord's Day
see you get ready for Memorial Day sir
you're not [__] lonely and then we
got another Church Tuesday night
Thursday night I'm at the [__]
flop is working it out again what uncle
Joey Diaz $10 to get in just putting
jokes together trying to get that new
[__] out what I need your help it's
that simple but all that should have
side it's a whole new week [__]
today you got the barbecue hang on ate
some [__] you talk to your bodies
tomorrow you write your goals and
[__] Tuesday you're ready to go out
the box like a fine Jack Lambert and
[__] 78 up there in Pittsburgh
knocking [__] out all day long
seven days a week and this damn you
gotta get out there that's one thing I
noticed just wait while I was sick I
couldn't get out and I thought to myself
I don't [__] do people just [__] sit
around
I got a move on [__] day I lose my
goddamn mind last night I went to bed
eight hours earlier because I couldn't
watch TV before
I felt too sick to write I couldn't
figure out how to [__] do people watch
TV or [__]
I can't understand there's what's wrong
with this [__] country I'm a [__]
[__] wait the [__] whatever the [__]
you call if I can't watch TV or they had
a [__] to people do it but anyway we
live we learned we sling dick and we
move on that's all you can [__] do
I'm here I'm queer seven days a week no
meat dog I don't give up I don't give a
[__] anymore I'm 54 I got one foot and a
couple spots this week if you're in town
I had a cancel the store last night with
[__] in my pants
I don't even tell you about the weeds I
got this we got perennial oh Jesus I got
cookies or oil cookies this shit's
[__] good it's a straight-up sativa
get your [__] up you gotta eat
something right away and what else you
got
we got a couple different races we got
this Larry Larry over there in Vegas
[__] talking lamb and beside
that it's a whole new week a whole new
set of rules
somebody's gonna suck it dick and at the
end of the day that's all their [__]
man is right at the end of the day
that's all that [__] matters you
write your goals you do your push-ups
you eat your carrots and you go out then
you like these [__] no you're
not gonna take it all right you're not
gonna take it you're gonna do what the
[__] you gonna do and you're gonna do it
150% they don't have to shoot you the
[__] leg to stop me
the same when they told me I got to do
deck you too I don't give a [__] how old
is the dick it's my world [__]
you [__] and visiting and I'm
only getting started you understand me
that's a good thing I'm only getting
started
I put thought into this [__] plan
understand me everything's precision
alright Peter my main man gregg allman
I saw him in Union City New Jersey one
time would share in front of [__]
Pastore music I almost [__] died he
was a savage and he taught alright beat
you guys no more anybody the Allman
Brothers make me go [__] bananas it's
like you're not through mourning one
[__] dude and the next dude [__]
dies you're not good morning [__]
Chris Cornell and now they talk
curveball I mean one of my all-time
[__] favorites gray woman my respect
to his family all the [__] that
rock his music and to the people that
came from the same cut as him white
geniuses that's all I just say Greg
Walkman was a white [__] genius don't
even make those no more don't make those
Einstein to suck my dick I'm talking
about taking it to the next level
Greg warm and the [__] now the other
ones that impose their will on you
[__] let it scan it [__]
ball something we [__] forgot go look
at their [__] down call the gate
lettuce get it from Oakland 77 they got
the five presidents up behind them they
got a confederate flag are you [__]
kidding me
anyway that's it guys dad let's move on
down the bulb I'm gonna call the [__]
ramp up at least I got to touch base
with you [__] like I said
tonight seven o'clock just does not let
you from all the [__] get out there
skittish
we got uncle Joey for you coming at you
and then tom is there with another
podcast with with the brief of mama it's
gonna come and educate us and then there
is damnit [__] flatness just like
that tip-top Magoo flappers at 7:30 just
doing an arrow on and I'm gonna keep
doing them every [__] Thursday night
either or either or and BAM
next thing you know we got a no [__]
hour you guys are happy you know me
though I'm the type of guy I like to
make up of notes in a notebook but I
gotta bring it up on the [__] stage
to really get the party started I give
give a [__] and you guys don't give a
[__] near door
I'm just thrown to the gills monkeys
talk just to keep you [__] amuse you
know what you that dude but you at least
I'm a watch that [__] because of my
little [__] food thing I haven't been
able to work out so I really wanted to
do a little workout today get the blood
golf so I'm ready for jiu-jitsu tip-top
[__] my go tomorrow and that's
it and that's that I love you
[__] with all my heart all
right I have a great day write your
[__] goals are the most important
thing at the end Zoro a weakness your
[__] goals you don't write your goals
today you're gonna have this [__]
[__] week how do I know because I've
been there
I didn't write my goals I went to jail
now I write my goals I said my living
room watch TV of my family understand
anyway
stay black have a tremendous Memorial
Day will do all these tomorrow morning
and I love you [__] Steve
tonight don't forget Thursday night flap
is Burbank one hour ten bucks we're
gonna get that tight like the table
don't go Joey to drench you might bump
into a star somebody might suck your
pipe it's Thursday night what get it
together I love you [__]